qu'est-il arrivé aux réverbères
attrapez la grande lumière vérifiez le côté nord
mettez vos mains en l'air
maintenant avez-vous eu des problèmes avec les
gens non je ne peux même pas expliquer ce que j'ai
vu je vais vous recommander de revenir à
service actif
allez mec c'est une histoire de quartier
nous n'allons nulle part
vous avez tous besoin de ces mains au-dessus de votre tête
vous pensez que je joue
18 sur 7 code 2 demandant une sauvegarde
continuez avec des précautions extrêmes
nous allons le prendre à partir d'ici  ça n'a
aucun sens, ils ont trouvé leurs gars,
laissez-les tranquilles,
regardez, j'ai besoin de toi dans wow
toutes ces choses qui continuent de se
produire signifient quelque chose que
quelqu'un est ici
[Musique]
toi